anna wieczorek zu besuch in zürich die
junge feministin ist in deutschland
längst ein bekanntes gesicht
vor zwei jahren setzte sie auf der
internetplattform twitter den hashtag
aufschrei ein sammelbegriff für sexismus
im alltag
damit löste sie eine lawine von
betroffenheits meldungen aus eine
sensation
selbst für die erfahrene social media
expertin aufgestanden und hatte
plötzlich die ersten interview-anfragen
hab gemerkt wie meine ganze twitter
timeline alleine redet schon komplett
über dieses thema und ist im grunde
schon komplett in dieser debatte drin
und das war wahnsinnig großartig dass zu
sehen
mein onkel der der meinung ist frauen
müssen haushalt und kinder machen
der typ den ich abblitzen ließ und für
den ich deswegen plötzlich eine fette
[ __ ] war der lehrer der auf der
abschlussfahrt die schülerinnen
befummelte und auf die wange küsste bis
heute wird der hashtag aufschrei von
eine wieczorek rege benutzt und tausende
einträge bezeugen alltag sexismus ist
auch heutzutage höchst aktuell
wenn auch oft unterschwellig die
frankfurter alleine angucken dann wird
zum beispiel immer impliziert vermittelt
männer sind per se kompetent genug für
diese führungsposten und bei frauen wird
es immer infrage gestellt also das wird
dann immer so subtil mit eingebaut und
das ist aber am ende die selbe
sexistische botschaften wie zu recht
bezeichnet sich selbst als netz
feministin
für sie ist das internet ein ideales
werkzeug um mehr menschen zu erreichen
und an der debatte teil haben zu lassen
doch wie nachhaltig sind solche
diskussionen in sozialen netzwerken
alle leute sind alle
bevölkerungsschichten sind da vertrete
so ein hersteller aufschrei kann so eine
initialzündung liefern ist aber am ende
nicht das einzige medium wo wir solche
debatten führen sollten also um das hat
nachhaltig zu diskutieren gerade solche
komplexen themen wie sexismus brauchen
wir immer noch andere plattformen haben
wir immer noch andere medien die das
auch weiterführen weil ein aufschrei
nicht recht laterne wieczorek ein buch
über den feminismus von heute
geschrieben
darin kritisiert sie vor allem das
patriarchalische gesellschaft system neu
ist das nicht und doch findet sie damit
anklang
verständlich zumal ihr buch locker und
provokativ geschrieben ist sich zuweilen
auch wie ein blog eintrag liest insofern
ist eine weibliche bundeskanzlerin ganz
war eine errungenschaft aber auch ein
problem dahinter verschwinden oder
versteckt werden
dabei sind ja auch eine angela merkel
oder eine ursula von der leyen nicht vor
sexismus geschützt wenn sie als mutter
oder als truppen ursel gezeichnet werden
war gerhard schröder etwa unser papier
oder wurde thomas de maizière
selbstverständlich als kasernen tommy
genannt anne wieczorek schreibt nicht
nur sie geht für die anliegen der frauen
auch auf die straße 2011 organisiert sie
in berlin einen so genannten slutwalk
mit frauen sollen nicht als sexualobjekt
ist sondern als menschen wahrgenommen
werden so die botschaft es geht um ein
gesamtgesellschaftliches problem
patriarchates neue gesellschaftsform die
für alle negative konsequenzen hat für
frauen selbstverständlich mehr deswegen
konzentriert sich finis muss erstmal auf
frauen
nichtsdestotrotz gibt es halt eben auch
negative auswirkungen auf männer dadurch
dass sie einfach in bestimmte diese
starke rolle gedrängt werden und
am ende ist es halt gensler wenn wir uns
von diesen diskriminierungs form lösen
profitieren männer genauso davon ein
feminismus von dem alle profitieren soll
eine wieczorek will brücken schlagen
zwischen den geschlechtern online wie
offline